it's not just what they're against but
what it is they're for and so farming in
recent votes we've seen MPs for lots of
different reasons voting against the
deer that the Prime Minister set out at
what we haven't seen is actually what
members of parliament will unite behind
let's look ahead today's vote because a
lot of people are asking what is the
point of it it can't stop a No Deal
only revoking article 50 can do that
well MPs themselves requested this
process the event Cooper and knit Bowles
and others requested a process and the
Prime Minister listened to the house and
has reflected that what we've seen is is
aid a in essence party politics from the
leader of the Opposition who as the
father of the house King Clark pointed
out to the chamber yesterday actually
there's nothing in the withdrawal
agreement in essence that he opposes but
full party political reasons he's voting
against and some of my other colleagues
on the concerta side and and also our
confidence of my partners in the DUP
will concern that there wasn't enough
clarity from the European Commission on
the exit provisions within the backstop
so we've been clear as to what MP has
been clear as to what they're against
what we now need to see is what they're
for
how will you be voting tonight well I
mean ultimately we need to see what
amendments a table that amendments have
been tabled overnight for a wide range
of issues such as to be very quick sit
entirely others in terms of proceeding
with no deal so we need to actually see
what the motion is I mean ultimately if
one plays this through to its end is
this this house declines to approve
leaving the EU without a withdrawal
agreement and a framework for the future
relationship on the 29th of March 2019
and notes that leaving without ADEA
remains the default in UK and EU law
unless this house and the EU ratify an
agreement it seems to be worded so that
the Prime Minister can vote against a No
Deal while keeping it on the table so
again I'll ask you how are you vote
given that wording well I mean I I think
if it's a choice ultimately between no
deal and no Greg seats then I think
neighbor exit is so catastrophic for
trust in our democracy that I can
support and no brexit outcome but in
terms of the precise motion before the
house we actually need to see what
amendments are firstly chosen by
the speaker and then secondly what
amendments are accepted by the house
because that will then be Tate what the
end motion is but we don't a huge amount
of work to prepare for No Deal but
there's no getting away from the fact
that no deal will be disrupted both
economically for businesses listening to
this but also to our you know tonight
there and give them what you've just
said know what I've just said is we need
to see what the motion is tonight
because we've tabled a government motion
for MPs will seek to amend to that
therefore the emotion we've actually
vote on may be different to the motion
tonight we need to actually see what
motion comes before the house and
there's a series of amendments which
have already been tabled to that motion
which what the house will need to
consider so there's a process around
this and we will set that out during the
course of the debate and in the meantime
what's happened to the prime ministers
do Boris Johnson said last night the
Prime Minister's deal has reached the
end of the road is it in the bin this
morning or could we see it again well
there's a huge amount in what has been
agreed with the European Union that MPs
on all sides of the House agree with
things like protecting the rights of EU
citizens working and living in the
United Kingdom things like respecting
legal obligations and an AMA being that
in terms of the financial settlement
ensuring we protect against a hard
border in Northern Ireland so the
shootaround in the deal that MPs say
they support and yet as you alluded to
at the start of this they voted against
the deal last night and a little
question for businesses and for people
watching this who face the uncertainty
of the vote last night is we've got the
announcement today in terms of the
consequence for tariffs what that will
mean for terrace paid by businesses and
how that will approach there's real term
consequences to the vote last night and
however the Parliament need to face up
to their responsibility to act in the
national interest to deliver on the
biggest vote in our history and respects
the referendum result both main parties
stood on manifesto saying they would
respect at the referendum result but
what we've now got from the labour party
is a party that's gone back on its word
to come back on what they tell voters at
the last general election now says it
wants a second referendum which would
simply prolong the uncertainty that
businesses up and down the country would
face
have you spoken to the Prime Minister
this morning I spoke to her last night
I've been doing a media round this
morning and so we've got cabinets at 8
o'clock so I will be speaking along with
colleagues with the program
yeah I'm just trying to gauge the mood
because obviously she was wasn't in
great voice yesterday and she said that
she will be at p.m. keys this afternoon
and will open the debate and so just
trying to get an idea of how she's doing
this morning in light of last night well
I think what people watching this will
see with the Prime Minister is someone
working every hour of the day in the
national interest to try and respect the
referendum result but do so in a way
that delivers for businesses and to
protect jobs and the real question for
for MPs who were voting against the deal
is what is the consequence of the
uncertainty and how that will impact on
businesses up and down the country